I've been talking to you about the sort
of right-wing authoritarian slide that's
been taking place in Turkey particularly
under president air dawuan maybe it's
partially why Donald Trump likes
president arrow on so much repression of
journalists air Dewan against the
internet brutal abuses when it comes to
press freedom lack of press freedom on
and on and on right this is a story
about Turkey and religion sometimes we
forget in the United States that
Christianity is not the only religion
whose followers deny the science of
evolution there's a senior education
official in the Turkish government who
announced that evolution is no longer
going to be taught in high school in
Turkey his name is alpha slander moose
who chairs the Turkish Board of
Education and he said listen evolutions
debatable its controversial and it's
just too complicated for high school
students he actually said in a video
that was posted to a Turkish government
website quote we believe that these
subjects are beyond their comprehension
referring of course to high school
students in Turkey
that's not even true I mean these are
high school students you can explain
evolution pretty well to first graders I
would say why can't high schoolers
understand it right I mean how
incredibly insulting is that to your own
people you can teach calculus and
trigonometry to high school students but
not something as basic as evolution and
they said that the chapter on evolution
is going to be removed from ninth grade
textbooks that they use there and get up
students are going to have to wait until
college I guess if they want to learn
about evolution evolution is maybe not
surprisingly not widely accepted among
Islamic clerics anywhere in the world
with some exceptions and Turkey's Deputy
Prime Minister Newman Kurt almost told
CNN earlier this year quote
scientifically the theory of evolution
is already an archaic and disproven
Theory there is no such rule that this
theory must be taught kurtulus also
complained in that same interview that
Turkish education has become too
Eurocentric and it needs to focus more
on the contributions of Islam this
decision
basically correlates with other trends
that we're seeing in Turkey which is
more religious schools known as Imam had
heap schools and uh we've spoken before
about prison president Erdogan desired
to raise a pious generation of Turks Oh
Doan has also gradually moved sort of to
reduce restrictions on the wearing of
Islamic dress back in 2011 he removed a
ban on head scarves in universities in
2013 he removed a similar ban in the
civil service this year he did the same
thing in the army it would be nice if
turkey used this new free time that they
have in school because they're no longer
going to teach evolution maybe to teach
students about the Armenian Genocide
which is still denied among the Turkish
society somehow I don't think that
that's what they're going to use this
newfound space in their curriculum for
well evolution has also denied largely
by Turkish society it goes much further
than air21 I a 2006 study out of
Michigan State ranked belief in
evolution by developed countries and
ranking last on that list at number 34
was Turkey do you know what was second
to last at number 33 again sizzler
is it the US the United States yeah
that's not surprising sad very low
energy but not particularly surprising
and none of this is really surprising as
I said earlier on who's been pushing
this authoritarian Islamic agenda since
day one education is probably the
scariest route for air to want to be
using because it's going to shape
multiple generations of Turks this is
the sort of definition of Islamism and
it's disturbing on two fronts number one
it's disturbing the serving because
Donald Trump likes air21 in his
administration
number two it's disturbing because
Turkey is often mentioned as the sort of
moderate secular Muslim country and
they've now eliminated evolution from
high school curriculum this is a steady
move in the direction of being a more
extreme Islamic nation and it is just
bad today's program sponsored in part by
tag adapt the hosting specialist whether
you need dedicated server solutions
Virtual Private servers cloud server
options custom server solutions
colocation services whatever you need
for your business or project taga dab
and their expert hosting specialists and
support will set you up with what works
for your business or project and their
hosting services support a really wide
range of customers and businesses around
the world including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more you can use the code
TDPS
20 to get a 20 british pound credit
towards cloud server options at signup
tag adapt calm /td PS with that you can
try out their services and save twenty
British pounds about 23 24 US dollars
you use the code TDPS
20 at sign up ta ga da be calm /td PS
check it out